you know what's funny about you me
you got bullied yeah but people wouldn't
expect that
no i did bullying but people wouldn't
expect i did both i at some point i had
to switch i had to bully [ __ ]
yeah you were bullied are you bullied oh
i believe the poop
i'm very open about it like oh
everybody's like i was believe no i had
to bully it was not all all black and
white that's something that at some
point if you didn't want to get bullied
you had to be like
bro i really don't want to do this but
you know i mean you had i had to yeah
just to get some
i couldn't take it no more yeah so i had
to i had to embark on that people don't
ask why people bully other [ __ ]
they just they just don't bully but yeah
people think i would be the one that was
bullied yeah
i mean it's a little tough i wouldn't
say i bullied i was i bullied folks
because i wasn't going out looking for
problems i kind of kept to myself but
promise found me and i'm like [ __ ]
let's go but i know you yes i know you
so i know you would be a bully
you know what's funny
you you know you know cow from the girl
from high school the asian girl yeah
she
we went to the same high school yeah
right
she's like
i didn't even know you were there
imagine going to the same high school
somebody's like you were at the same
high school yeah because we met up later
because she didn't have to know she was
one of the cute ones
she was hired here but my point is i was
you was dusty see but if i was a bully
you would know me
that's what i'm saying i was invisible
but if you try to make me visible we're
gonna have a problem
i kept to myself and especially because
i was fresh off the boat
yeah you don't want that kind of i was
fresh off the boat looking weird yo
i was like six feet tall 140 pounds
[ __ ] was looking at me weird big ass
afro i wore a sweat sweater like 24 7.
yeah so mother was looking at me crazy
but you still do so you're basically the
same [ __ ] yes okay yeah but i'm just
not 140.
[Music]
so so so so at that time
like problems would find me all the time
and i would i was wild back then but
it's just interesting
how i think people perceive you they
wouldn't expect that you have that past
no no they wouldn't that's a fact that's
true people wouldn't want to think oh he
was bullying and everything and stuff
it was brutal too and you know this is
so cliche but my experience with people
who
engaged in that behavior
was
that they really were insecure
there was a deep-seated insecurity from
my perspective knowing them the ones
that i knew
some of them some of them were just
pieces of [ __ ]
there's just some garbage human being
maybe it was because they were
uh insecure but yeah but that's what i'm
saying that insecurity is what i think
drives them to engage in that behavior i
know there was one all right his name
was all right this [ __ ] was a
big old [ __ ]
okay because when he was a in a group he
was laughing at people laughing at me
laughing at [ __ ] all the time
and then we would be alone in the bus
this [ __ ] wouldn't even look at
me and i'm like oh you are a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
you a big old [ __ ] but that's that's
not wanting to conform to the group you
know the group goes one way you don't
want to be a dude
yeah you just kind of you kind of go
with it you feel me but i remember one
kid in my high school he couldn't fight
for [ __ ] he couldn't fight but he was
big and he ended up starting taking
steroids and i remember one time he
tried to roll up on me and i almost took
this nigga's eyes out and then everybody
looked at him as a punk after that but i
could see
that what had happened to him was what
he feared the most that people saw how
much of the weakness because yo let me
catch an l if you think i'm gonna walk
around like a [ __ ] i'll fight you again
next week's stupid i'll take another one
i was deranged right so i knew looking
at him that he just had that insecurity
i had my own issues in my own secures
but what drove him to try to be
aggressive towards people even though he
was scared shitless
was wanting to project that image yeah
definitely and i think that kind of
carries over for most of the folks who
feel the need to do that is there's a
need to want to assert your dominance
over others because you are not in
control of yourself does that make sense
yeah
and you don't strike me as a bully we'll
see
nah i don't think so i was probably also
invisible i was always in like i was in
like a nerd program that only the nerds
were in in my school yeah who was that
tamagotchi
no it's called like it's like the
international program
exactly yeah
yeah yeah you were not even in [ __ ]
but they have their university they have
no no no so
so it was it was so it was it was it was
international studies
it was just like an advanced program
yeah
exactly so i was with the same like 30
kids for a while and then i changed
schools and whatever so
i feel like when i was younger may like
i look back some you ever look back and
you're like maybe i was a bit of a bully
because i did like to joke around and
oftentimes you just make fun of people
around you you know what i mean yeah
and i remember in grade six especially
in high school is pretty quiet i wasn't
like a big joker i just kind of put my
head down but in elementary i i'm i'm i
wilded it like i [ __ ] love to just
make people laugh you know yeah i think
that's where the love of like wanting to
do stand-up whenever i would do a uh
like an oral presentation i love that
[ __ ] yeah oh you was like roast kids for
no reason and i look back and i'm like
man are those those kids like are they
talking about me like that guy was a
[ __ ] dick yeah you might have been a
dick but i think being a bully requires
some intention to want to
intimidate or to make someone feel
really terrible about themselves and it
also needs some consistency a one-off
comment or a roast every now and then i
don't think it's the same as like
targeting people consistently to try to
intimidate them or to make them cower
from you i think that's when i think you
cross over into believe i don't think
that yeah bully has consistency yeah
you're always on you know
i'm sure i've heard people's feelings
just yeah i just made them hasn't right
yeah who has to give one comment is not
bullying no like it's one comment you
you heard one thing and you know it made
you cry big [ __ ] move on with your day
you know what i mean but that's not a
bully you just heard some [ __ ] that made
you i was a real piece of [ __ ] in
elementary school you still are yeah
i was like the biggest [ __ ] disturber
you could imagine i i pissed off my
teacher so bad he ended up assaulting me
and he had got fired he assaulted you
yeah yeah i never forget i was like i
was the worst wait a minute that was the
worst the [ __ ] assaulted you
i never forget it like you threw you get
like he pushed you like so i'll never
forget this
i'll never forget this this this was a
lot so
i was
this was like maybe third fourth grade
i was young i was really tiny and we
were like you know how you used to have
to line up before going to class
everybody get in line yeah before going
inside
and i was always just like talking some
[ __ ] you know
and he would always like get on me and
i'm like
and i i don't know what it was i said
but i remember being in the hallway and
i said something
and this tall white dude he was pretty
decent shape
and he got mad he said something felt
that yard
i was
you know still doing my life whatever
[ __ ] whatever nick
i just remember him grabbing me lifting
me off the ground like i never like went
up so fast like an elevator and this man
just slammed me against the wall in the
hallway in front of everybody everyone
turned around and then he just dropped
me on the floor
yeah and crazy i didn't even cry i
remember that but i remember going back
home when i told my sister my sister
lost her mind then my mom lost her mind
he went right to the school it was a big
thing and he ended up uh getting let go
mr villeneuve i'll never forget his name
shout out to you mr vanessa yeah i
pissed him off
i pissed him off i could understand yeah
i i i i was i was i was a shitty kid
it was a shitty kid
it's like
i was a [ __ ] disturber let out
constantly say something i wasn't like i
was malicious going like stab people and
crazy but you know if you wanted order i
wanted my
my last year of of elementary school i
had a teacher mr shir
and i was yeah in the school in the
class
i was the guy that was saying some [ __ ]
that was funny he always seems to sleep
because he was an old dude always trying
to be interesting and stuff like that
and you know sometimes it was he was
feeling us he was feeding us [ __ ]
and i was like
no mr sure
that ain't it that and i was constantly
reminding him of that so whenever
like that's where i discovered sarcasm
and quit wit so i was inspiring myself
from fresh prince of bel air and that
ruined me because i was always on this
case every time that he had like
something to say that i thought that was
funny boom i was like i'm about to say
some dumb [ __ ] right now just to make
the people laugh that was the only
gratification i could get did he assault
you no he didn't he couldn't
small he's he's tall dude but come on
he's an old dude brittle and [ __ ] bam i
was always a starkey dude
like i think i was like in
sixth grade and i was still sixth
grade's pretty big yeah you're starting
to get bigger i was like this size in
grade six yeah yeah yeah yeah grade six
you start to get pretty big you start to
get to your you know you're not you're
full size but you're different yeah i
was six i was in grade six and i was
like 170. wow yeah me too something like
that it was 5 10 17. i was playing
football i was doing it like definitely
i was going tracking feeling [ __ ] no
you could try me but
if i kick you yeah
that man [ __ ] me up i'm just that's wild
i as a as a person who's taught kids
i've envisioned doing that yeah yes of
course as an adult i sympathize with
them oh yeah definitely because i can
imagine how like annoying and every day
after day and you have a bad day and
there's one kid who won't shut the [ __ ]
up
you know but those were the days were
before cell phone cameras yeah it would
have been today that [ __ ] would
have been on tick-tock tick-tock
tick-tock soon as you pick me up
what's up [ __ ]
on everything tick tock challenge who's
gonna get fired tonight this
[ __ ] would be like hey today i'm
gonna risk it all yes he [ __ ] grabbed
you yeah
there's not too many marriages from my
childhood that are very vivid that one
that one is vivid yeah